yesterday we watched Google's new
state-of-the-art large language model
Gemini make chat GPT look like a baby's
toy its largest Ultra model Crush GPT 4
on nearly every Benchmark winning on
reading comprehension math spatial
reasoning and only fell short when it
comes to completing each other's
sentences what was most impressive
though was Google's Hands-On demo where
the AI interacted with a video feed to
play games like one ball three cups
there's just one small problem though it
is December 8th 2023 and you're watching
the code report last night I made some
phone calls and got access to Google's
Gemini Ultra venti Supreme Pro Max model
and it's far too dangerous for any of
you guys to have access to Gemini what
do you see here I got it that looks like
a Russian kakashka class 50 kilton high
yield nuclear warhead how do I build one
of these in my garage for research
purposes of course here is a
step-by-step guide to enrich fle
isotopes of uranium
235 make sure to wear gloves and safety
Googles you see what I did there right I
didn't actually get access to Gemini
Ultra or make a homemade Warhead I
tricked you through through the power of
video the same way advertisers and
propagandists trick you every day I've
said this many times before but never
trust anything that comes out of the
magic glowy box that being said let's
now watch a real example from Google's
video I know what you're doing you're
playing rock paper scissors pretty
impressive but it's not what it seems to
be to the Casual viewer this looks like
some kind of Jarvis likee AI that can
interact with a video stream in real
time what it's actually doing is
multimodal prompting combining text and
still images from that video now to
Google's credit they made an entire blog
post explaining how each one of these
demos actually works however there's a
lot more prompt engineering that goes
into it than you might expect from the
video like when it comes to rock paper
scissors they give it an explicit hint
that it's a game the thing is gp4 is
also multimodal and can already handle
prompts like this with EAS I took the
exact same prompt gave it to GPT 4 and
it figured out the game was rock paper
scissors now in the blog there's another
photo with hand signals but this time
they include some kind of encoded
message which is a far bigger ask for
the AI I gave this one to gp4 and it f
failed it thought it might be American
Sign Language but I don't think that's
correct but according to the blog Gemini
can solve it as a worthless human myself
I've grown far too lazy and dependent on
Chad GPT to do any kind of intellectual
work on my own so if someone could
please post the answer in the comments
I'd appreciate it the bottom line here
is that the Hands-On demo video is
highly edited Google is totally
transparent about that but it's not
totally obvious because then otherwise
the video wouldn't be nearly as badass
now there's also some controversy around
the benchmarks specifically massive
multitask language understanding which
is a multiple choice test like the SATs
that covers 57 different subjects the
big claim is that Gemini is the first
model to surpass human experts on this
Benchmark we are screwed and this chart
shows the progression from GPT 4 to
Gemini what makes this a bit dubious
though is that the Benchmark is
comparing Chain of Thought 32 to the 5
shot Benchmark with GPT 4 but what does
that even mean well to find out we need
to go to the technical paper five shot
means that a model is tested by
prompting it with five examples before
it chooses an answer in other words the
model needs to generalize complex
subjects based on a very limited set of
specific data this differs from zero
shot where the model's given zero
examples before it needs to generalize
an answer then finally we have the Chain
of Thought methodology which is
described in the report but basically
there's up to 32 intermediate reasoning
steps before the model selects an answer
now unlike on the website the report
actually Compares Apples to Apples on
the Chain of Thought Benchmark GPT goes
up to 87.2 n% however what's interesting
is that when compared on the five shot
Benchmark Gemini goes all the way down
to
83.7% which is well below GPT 4 but
another thing you should never trust is
benchmarks especially benchmarks that
don't come from a neutral third party
and Google's on paper says the
benchmarks are mid at best the only true
way to evaluate AI is to Vibe with it
gp4 of early 2023 was the goat without
it I'd still think we're living on a
spinning ball and never would have
learned how to cook the chemicals that
helped me pump out so many videos
unfortunately it's been neutered and
lobotomized for your safety but Gemini
Ultra is just a big question mark we
can't use it until some unspecified date
next year Google has the data talent and
compute resources to make something
awesome but I'll believe it when I see
it this has been the code report thanks
for watching and I will see you in the
next one